لقد تم اعتبار الأشخاص الآسيويين كبش فداء
طوال تاريخ هذا البلد
والعديد من الآسيويين الذين أعرفهم الآن ،
إنهم أكثر خوفًا من التعرض للهجوم
أكثر من خوفهم من التعاقد مع فيروس كورونا ،
فإن التاريخ حقًا مروع للغاية
كما قلت أنه تم تحديده على وجه التحديد
من أجلك تعرف  أكثر من قرن
آه وليزا تعلمون لأنك تراها
كل يوم في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بك أنه لا أحد محصنًا ، أعني
أن الأشياء التي تم إرسالها إليك
هي مجرد أشياء [ __ ] وسأقرأ
بعضها وأعتذر عنها  اضطررت
لقراءة هذه الأشياء للناس ،
هذه هي الأشياء التي كان عليك
الوصول إليها ، أغلقك فارغًا ،
يجب أن يبقى كل آسيوي بعيدًا ، لقد
أصابنا جميعًا بالمرض ،
آمل أن تموت جميعًا ، أتمنى أن يموت
أطفالك حتى الموت
بسبب فيروس ووهان ، أعني هذا فقط
أشياء مثيرة للاشمئزاز ليزا ، ما رأيك في
قراءة ذلك
نعم جون الثاني أتمنى أن أقول إن هذه كانت
الرسالة الوحيدة التي تلقيتها ، لقد
تلقيت العديد من
الرسائل المشابهة في جميع أنحاء
الوباء
ويبدو أنه من الصعب قراءتها  من
المؤلم قراءتها
ولكن الصفات العرقية قد تأرجحت في
اتجاهي
طوال حياتي ، يمكنني أن أعتبر
أن الأشخاص الذين تعرضوا
للبصق على هجوم وحشي قد تم قتلهم
فقط بسبب لون بشرتهم
الذي يثير غضبي ،
والآن ما أقصده ليزا  ما الذي يتغير
داخل
المجتمع الآسيوي حول كيفية مكافحة
هذا الأمر
بشكل جيد ، علينا أن نستمر في الحديث عن
هذا الأمر وآمل أن يقف الناس خارج
المجتمع الآسيوي
معنا ويدينون هذه
الهجمات العنصرية.